There was once an emperor who loved clothes.
One day, a man said to his friend, "We can make some money."
"We can make magic clothes."
"But we don't know how to make magic clothes," his friend said.
"I know. But no one knows that. The emperor doesn't know that. Here is my plan."
"Your plan may work," his friend said. "Let's try."
The two men went to the emperor's room.
He was putting on some new clothes.
"We can make better clothes than those," one of the men said.
"In fact, our clothes are so wonderful that stupid people cannot even see them!"
"I want to be able to tell who the stupid and clever people are in my empire,"...
...the emperor thought.
He told the two men, "Make me some of your clothes. I will give you a lot of money."
The next day, the two men came to the palace.
"Here are your new magic clothes," they said to the emperor.
"Put them on and you will be able to tell the stupid and clever people in your empire."
The emperor called all of his ministers.
He told them to walk with him through the city.
He wanted to show the people his new magic clothes.
Everyone knew about the emperor's magic clothes.
They could not see them, but they did not want others to think they were stupid.
Then, a small boy said to his father,...
..."Dad, the emperor isn't wearing any clothes."
Then, a man standing nearby said, "The boy is right."
Soon, everyone was shouting.
"They are right," he thought.
"I'm not wearing any clothes."
He did not know what to do, so he kept on walking.